Neil deGrasse Tyson is with us he's a
leading astrophysicist we're continuing
our conversation with Roger stone margie
phelps is with us of course of the
Westboro Baptist Church I'm joined today
by Richard Spencer who's the editor of
alt-right calm
Elizabeth Warren really great to see you
today and thanks for coming in it's so
nice to see welcome to the David Pakman
show YouTube channel first things first
please make sure to subscribe to the
channel and click the bell to get
notifications for new videos and
livestreams we put out about six to
eight videos every day we interview
important figures on the national stage
everyone from politicians scientists
even racist and homophobic extremists
you'll also hear from our haters we get
a lot of hate mail we even have a
segment called hatred mail we also do
live streams on YouTube and every day we
bring you analysis of the day's top news
stories from a progressive independent
perspective why does Donald Trump lie
about such meaningless things in
provably demonstrably false ways any
reasonably intelligent person and Putin
is one for sure right knows by now
exactly how to manipulate Donald Trump
what issue got you voting for Trump
today I think we need leadership in this
country it's gotten as crazy as Saturday
Night Live in the actual real Trump
White House a ringing endorsement for
Donald Trump here thank you I really
appreciate speaking to the David Pakman
show
is 100% independently produced and
independent media is more important now
than ever if you want to resist
corporate media and stay up-to-date on
news and politics and the insanity of
the current White House or if you want
to check out interviews that are always
interesting and sometimes outrageous I
hope you'll stick around check
everything out that the David Pakman
show has to offer